Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Cristina Bufi-Pöcksteiner
Questo è il tempo delle donne.
Lo avevate notato?
Questo è il tempo delle donne,
viviamo nel tempo delle donne.
Le donne sono protagoniste
di questo tempo,
nel mondo occidentale, oggi.
Le donne sono dappertutto.
Le donne sono protagoniste nella società,
nel mondo del lavoro, nella politica,
nella istituzioni, nell'arte,
nella cultura, nella scienza.
Le donne sono protagoniste.
Non c'è problema, questione, progetto
che non venga analizzato
pensando al punto di vista delle donne,
all'impatto di genere,
alla prospettiva di genere,
all'effetto dal
punto di vista femminile.
Le donne, quindi, sono
protagoniste di questo tempo.
Ma le donne non sono soltanto
protagoniste di questo tempo;
le donne sono anche vittime
di questo tempo,
o meglio vittime di questi tempi.
I tempi delle donne
non sono i tempi degli uomini.
Le donne hanno abdicato al loro tempo,
per donarlo agli altri.
Il concetto della relatività del tempo
della fisica teorica
si concretizza perfettamente
nella vita delle donne.
Il tempo delle donne
non è il tempo degli uomini.
Le donne sono divise tra tanti tempi:
il tempo della vita familiare;
il tempo della procreazione;
il tempo dell allevamento
e della cura dei figli;
il tempo del lavoro.
Alle donne si chiede tantissimo:
si chiede di essere sempre in forma,
di riuscire a soddisfare
i tempi degli altri.
Se chi è il vero ricco, la persona felice,
è la persona che ha del tempo
- del tempo per sé stesso,
del tempo per donare agli altri -
beh, diciamo che le donne
sono povere di tempo per sé stesse.
Le donne hanno poco tempo per loro,
perché donano il loro tempo agli altri:
alle donne si chiede tempo.
Se dobbiamo descrivere
la vita di una donna lavoratrice,
madre - magari di un figlio piccolo -
come la descriveremmo?
Che cosa vi viene in mente?
Noi siamo sempre di corsa.
La nostra vita è una corsa,
è una corsa contro il tempo,
un incastro continuo.
Siamo vittime della mancata
conciliazione dei tempi,
siamo vittime della difficile,
a volte impossibile
conciliazione dei tempi.
Siamo vittime del multitasking:
a noi si chiede di essere madri perfette,
di essere il focolare,
il centro del focolare domestico,
il fulcro della famiglia tradizionale
e non tradizionale.
Ma a noi si chiede anche
di essere lavoratrici brave, bravissime;
di essere competitive
con i colleghi uomini,
di sfondare la barriera di cristallo;
di arrivare ai vertici.
Quindi, alle donne si chiede tantissimo.
Ma alle donne non si dà altrettanto.
Le donne - le donne moderne,
le donne del mondo occidentale,
le donne protagoniste -
si trovano in una situazione difficile.
Siamo donne in bilico, spesso costrette
a delle scelte drammatiche.
Rinunciare a una parte di noi,
rinunciare all'idea
della procreazione, o posticiparla.
E sappiamo che posticiparla troppo,
a volte, significa rinunciare.
E dall'altro lato, a volte,
sacrificare il lavoro,
sacrificare la carriera.
Siamo in bilico, donne in bilico,
una dimensione individuale
di profonda drammaticità.
Alle donne si impone una scelta,
una scelta drammatica
che non è la scelta
che si impone agli uomini.
Siamo quindi sempre sottoposte
a una pressione molto forte,
che viviamo in una dimensione individuale.
Ma questo è l'errore: non è
una dimensione individuale.
In realtà, questo è
un problema collettivo,
perché il problema individuale
diventa un problema collettivo
nel momento in cui ha
un impatto collettivo.
Perché le donne sono il fulcro
del mercato del lavoro.
Aumentare l'occupazione, in questo paese,
significa aumentare
l'occupazione femminile.
È l'occupazione femminile
che è più bassa di quella maschile:
anzi, in Italia l'occupazione femminile
è tra le più basse nei paesi europei.
La disoccupazione femminile
è più bassa di quella maschile.
Il tasso di inattività
femminile è altissimo.
Tasso di inattività significa
che le donne hanno rinunciato a sperare.
Il tasso di inattività
è un indice di sfiducia
delle donne nel mercato.
È l'indice del fatto
che le donne sono sfiduciate:
o sono state espulse dal mercato,
o non ci sono entrate,
ma hanno rinunciato a cercarlo.
È un dato di profonda tristezza,
il dato di inattività.
E allora, aumentare
l'occupazione nel paese
significa aumentare
l'occupazione femminile,
puntare sulle donne,
rilanciare il lavoro delle donne.
Dall'altro lato,
guardiamo però questo paese.
Questa dimensione individuale
di drammatica scelta
ha portato a un bassissimo
tasso di natalità.
Il tasso di natalità, in questo paese,
è tra i più bassi al mondo,
ben al di sotto del livello di rimpiazzo.
Siamo un paese che non cresce:
poco lavoro e pochi figli.
Troppo pochi figli, troppo poco lavoro.
C'è un problema,
c'è un corto circuito: che fare?
E allora vediamo che quella dimensione
di drammaticità individuale
diventa una dimensione
che ha una proiezione collettiva,
una proiezione importante
per il nostro Paese.
Non è quindi un affare individuale;
è un affare collettivo, è un affare
che ha a che fare con lo Stato.
È un affare di Stato, è la politica
che si deve occupare di questo.
È la politica che deve
puntare sulle donne.
Da giuslavorista, vi dico:
è vero che ci sono molte tutele,
nel mercato del lavoro.
Il diritto del lavoro prevede
molte tutele, nel mercato,
per le lavoratrici.
Ma quali lavoratrici?
Le lavoratrici subordinate!
Le tutele sono fondamentalmente incentrate
nel rapporto di lavoro subordinato.
Ma guardiamoci intorno:
com'è il mercato del lavoro, oggi?
Il mercato del lavoro sta cambiando:
non è più soltanto
il lavoro subordinato, anzi!
Il diritto del lavoro, però,
si è dimenticato
di una parte delle lavoratrici:
le autonome, le libere professioniste,
le lavoratrici a voucher.
La famosa gig ecomony ha
quasi polverizzato il rapporto di lavoro.
Si è trasformato:
ci sono tanti, tanti tipi di lavori,
e la maggior parte di questi
non sono tutelati.
Le lavoratrici allora sono divise
tra chi ha tantissime tutele
e chi ne ha poche.
Ma anche chi ha tante tutele, in realtà,
non ha la fortuna
di poter fare con serenità delle scelte.
Perché?
Perché le troppe tutele sono un boomerang.
Molte volte, le troppe tutele
si trasformano in un boomerang.
E accade allora che un datore di lavoro,
invece che assumere una lavoratrice,
che si porta dietro una dote
di pacchetto di tutele,
assume un lavoratore, un uomo,
proprio per evitare quelle tutele.
E allora bisogna fare qualcosa,
bisogna cambiare il punto di vista,
bisogna cambiare la prospettiva.
Dobbiamo partire da una constatazione:
le donne in questo paese
rappresentano un pezzo del welfare.
Le donne hanno sostituito lo Stato
in tutta una serie di situazioni.
Le donne si occupano
dei figli, li allevano;
si occupano degli anziani, li accudiscono;
le donne arrivano
dove lo Stato non arriva.
Le donne sono un pezzo di welfare.
E allora, se la politica e lo Stato
devono investire sul welfare,
e se le donne sono un pezzo di welfare,
lo Stato deve investire sulle donne.
Investire sulle donne
significa metterci soldi,
significa scommettere sulle donne,
scommettere in particolare sulle donne
giovani, sulle nuove generazioni,
per cambiare il paese,
per far andare avanti il paese.
Come fare, come scommettere sulle donne?
Io voglio lanciare un'idea,
perché a TED si lancia un'idea,
un'idea che puo essere un progetto,
o può essere presa come una provocazione.
Un'idea che però
è un'idea concretizzabile.
Si parla di reddito minimo:
io darei un reddito minimo di maternità.
Un reddito minimo di maternità
alle donne che rinunciano
a una parte della loro attività lavorativa
per l'accudimento dei figli.
E soltanto per un tempo limitato,
magari fino ai 13 anni di vita dei minori.
Rinunciare a una parte del tempo di lavoro
per l'allevamento
e la procreazione dei figli.
Un reddito minimo di maternità
che consenta alle donne
- a prescindere dalla tipologia
di contratto di lavoro:
subordinate, autonome, voucher,
libere professioniste, a prescindere.
Un reddito di dignità,
per consentire alle donne
di non essere sempre sottoposte
a questa drammatica scelta,
di poter prendersi una pausa lavorativa
- ma restando con un piede nel mercato -
per l'accudimento dei figli.
E per un accudimento dei figli
che non deve essere limitato
ai primi anni di vita dei figli,
perché noi italiane
non abbiamo la stessa cultura
delle donne nordeuropee,
delle donne nordamericane.
La donna italiana
vuole essere una madre italiana:
vuole esserci,
nella vita dei propri figli.
Vuole essere protagonista,
vuole essere un punto di riferimento.
Vuole esserci.
E allora dobbiamo consentire alle donne
di soddisfare questa esigenza,
di fare questa scelta.
Un reddito minimo di maternità,
che però imponga alle donne,
in cambio, di rimanere nel mercato.
Con formazione
- perché la formazione
è un investimento per sé stessi,
è un investimento per il futuro,
è un investimento per ritornare a lavorare
dopo il periodo di pausa -
oppure con una serie
di attività lavorative.
Dobbiamo prendere il buono,
per esempio, che c'è nella gig economy,
nella collaborative economy,
nella sharing economy.
Il lavoretto, la flessibilità negativa,
può essere montata al positivo,
se è vista come conciliativa.
Una forma di conciliazione
che consenta alla lavoratrice,
che decide che per i primi
13 anni di vita dei suoi figli
si occuperà principalmente di loro,
di tenere un piede nel mercato,
di non mollare completamente,
in modo da essere facilmente, poi,
reimmessa in un circolo di produzione.
Ecco, questo può essere
uno spunto, un'idea.
Vorrei aggiungere ancora una cosa:
accanto a questo,
dovrebbe esserci anche
una contribuzione figurativa aggiuntiva.
Una contribuzione figurativa aggiuntiva
che sopperisca alle carenze contributive
della lavoratrice che si sacrifica
in questo periodo di vita.
Perché dobbiamo pensare alla pensione.
E allora, se esiste la contribuzione
figurativa aggiuntiva, per esempio,
per i lavoratori usuranti,
io la prevederei anche per le donne.
L'usura non sarebbe data dal lavoro,
ma dal doppio, dal triplo lavoro,
magari in proporzione
al numero dei figli allevati.
Ecco allora che si investirebbe
in modo concreto,
si darebbe uno strumento concreto:
un reddito minimo di maternità,
una contribuzione figurativa aggiuntiva.
Lo Stato ci dovrebbe mettere quindi soldi,
ma consentirebbe in questo modo
alle donne di fare il salto.
Ma anche il Paese potrebbe fare il salto,
perché abbiamo capito che sono le donne
la chiave di volta del sistema.
Sono le donne che possono
far aumentare l'occupazione.
Sono le donne che possono aumentare
la sostenibilità del welfare,
e sono le donne che possono
far crescere il paese,
in termini di popolazione.
Naturalmente, bisognerebbe
sperimentare queste misure.
Dove?
Per esempio nelle pubbliche
amministrazioni, ma non solo.
Bisognerebbe coinvolgere le imprese,
le imprese che con responsabilità sociale
si vogliono far carico di questo,
di dare delle occasioni
di lavoro alle donne.
Delle occasioni di lavoro
anche flessibile, molto flessibile,
con incentivi alle imprese
che decidono di rappresentare
uno strumento per le donne,
per non perdere completamente
il contatto col mercato.
Questa potrebbe essere un'idea
per far fare il salto.
Un'idea per limitare
la disoccupazione femminile,
per aumentare l'occupazione femminile,
per sconfiggere l'inattività femminile
e per portare l'inclusione
delle donne
che decidono - in parte,
per una parte della propria vita -
di dedicarsi principalmente
alla famiglia, ai figli,
ma senza rinunciare alle loro aspirazioni
di indipendenza economica,
di carriera, di futuro.
E poi, questo potrebbe anche servire
per far ritrovare la voglia di natalità.
Grazie.
(Applausi)